now speaking of being your knees we you
just got it engaged I literally have
just been in this position
um yes
exactly like this
I'm getting flashbacks
um how did it go I just proposed to my
girlfriend Ramona
[Applause]
um and so and I got I was like do I get
down on my knee what do I do and I was
like what did you may as well so I got
down on one knee and then she like what
you're doing goes well you can't be the
only one on your knees so she got down
as well yes because she's a giver not a
taker yes and we were in the Disneyland
the happiest proposal place on Earth
um and um so we're in the middle of
Disneyland proposing
um and luckily they put some topiary
trees around us to give us a little bit
of privacy and it was just beautiful and
she said yes and then I was like oh okay
great
um and then I was so overwhelmed that
afterwards we went on a ride this new
ride they had and I kind of collapsed
afterwards because I was so like
overwhelmed with because I'd never been
engaged before or proposed to or
proposed so it was like such a huge
thing in my life and then we went on
this new ride and I go hang on I just
have to like and I just like literally
collapsed on the floor for like five
minutes and then I go okay I'm good
let's get chiros and um
they also picked up the phone and called
Bob Iger yes like the president of all
of Disney the Grand Puba like yeah he's
the big the big big boss and I thought
well if he says yes then it was meant to
be and I was meant to propose that day
at Disneyland and because I had to get
special permission to get a special area
roped off and get the topiary trees in
and uh you know and a violinist playing
like Disney Classics and it was very
yeah it was really romantic so I just I
did go to the big boss to get permission
it's like
the one yeah yeah like that's so cool
yeah and they couldn't close down the
whole park we just got one little
section I love that there's so much sort
of beauty and romance and elegance to
the way that you went about it and I was
curious that you started a new dating
app yes that's right yeah it's called
fluid everyone and you can download it
now
um and it was kind of like inspired by
my journey to love and I you know and
probably like you know I was on a dating
app and uh I think we're on the same one
yeah yeah yeah yeah
um and it was on that dating app you had
to kind of tick a box and you kind of
had to label yourself and label what
you're interested in uh who you were
interested in and I always felt weird
and I take doll I'm a woman interested
in men and and then it felt really weird
and some of the pitch perfect girls were
like oh if you take women interested in
women you can check out your competition
um and so like I and I ticked it once
and then and then uh some I don't know
newspaper said I was bisexual or
whatever and I went oh wait they found
out yeah you know because that's the
whole point of that privacy so I just
thought well what if there's a dating
app where you don't have to label
yourself or what you're interested in
because I do think from my own journey
and I'm obviously in an amazing same-sex
relationship now but with someone who
primarily dated men before that and and
so what if I'd had a dating act where I
could be free to explore and then I
didn't have to label myself and I think
sexuality is so much more complex and
nuanced than you know having to put a
label and I guess if you ask any young
young like Superstar like Harry Styles
or lizzo or whatever like they're all
they're all over this fluid concept
um but to me it was different and I and
I thought oh if only that dating app had
been around five years ago it would have
helped me yeah because I just think that
you're at no I'm a weirdo I'm sorry
um I I do think that there is a white
space a Marketplace I need
um you know well it's a very like I
think some of the other dating apps are
now outdated a bit because there is a
need for this new concept of fluidity
and you know and your sexuality May
slightly change and this app will the
algorithm will go with you
um and just you know you're open to more
possibilities actually you're open to a
wider dating pool well which could be
beneficial so excited for us and it's
something that I you know is so
important to me and I was inspired by a
lot of the young kids on my movies
senior year and I was like well there's
no dating app for them right now well
thanks to you I'll get okay
[Applause]
in my spare time
thanks to Rebel
now now there is one of my hardest part
uh I love this being on the dating app
is I can't figure out who the hell
anyone is
the guys they put the weirdest
they put the weirdest things I'm wearing
it on the app for their description
and then the whole point is you could go
into their Instagram account to find
them mine now I've got my miners cap on
and uh you know I need a PI license to
figure out who anybody is now all the
Instagram accounts are private so
whatever gets a little bit of
information out there would also be
appreciated
[Music]
foreign